did you see when i thought marlon mariah
yeah i wasn't at that one but i saw that
one that was great that was probably one
of the best comebacks i've ever seen
yeah
yeah mma i'm gonna give him props on
that one i thought i ain't gonna lie
after that first round i go oh [ __ ]
he kicks you one more time i said my
guy's gone that was one of the best
[Music]
what's up everybody guys welcome to this
episode of hot boxing here with mike
tyson
we are at a special place today we're at
tyson's ranch and resorts
and uh this is yours truly king triple c
and i'm mike tyson and the day we got
here no other but mr dynamite missed the
sensational
mr cool and himself mario lopez
thank you champ it's a pleasure to be
here i appreciate uh appreciate the time
love hanging with you guys right here
man so tell me what's going on lately in
your life i'm good man you know i've
been uh
i've been thank god very very busy right
now it uh professionally
and and personally i could i couldn't be
happier you know i'm uh
even this whole year during coving man i
was like the busiest i've ever been i
was still doing um
my shows at nbc access hollywood all
access and access daily
and then i got my nationally syndicated
radio show on with mario that i do every
day
right
it's crazy man because then at the same
time i did all that and then i brought
back save by the bell
and i did uh that for uh peacock in a
new season and we're getting ready to do
the second
season of that and then i just finished
a little um uh
christmas movie called holiday in santa
fe my daughter comes out in it so you
know
just been uh just been real busy all the
while i always say the toughest thing is
trying to find the time to train
so you know still boxing and jiu jitsu
and wrestling
taking care of the kids and everything
so you know
if i don't train i don't eat i want to
eat that day
that's a great that's a great uh model
to live by right there too because i eat
what i ate
that day if i don't um train yeah that's
good discipline and most people
discipline like that probably wouldn't
have
an obesity issue i don't know i just
know that everyone is
everybody's everybody's different yeah
yeah no different lifestyle
i don't feel like i ever really woke up
unless i busted a sweat you know i'm the
same way too but some people
that's just overbearing what's this
that's what um bothers some people yeah
people are different we're all different
i love to sweat though i feel you know
more alive and everything so yeah that's
cool
i also see a lot of your instagram you
are you i mean you spent time with
freddie roach
yeah i know i've been and now mike's
seen me in there i've been in there uh
i've been going to freddy's man for a
long time like 20 years
yes did you spart against the usher do
you guys fart against each other yeah i
support i support a little
he was training um right yeah if he was
playing sugar ray leonard
for hands of stone he was cool you know
we just moved light and stuff but he's
he's athletic he's had a little kid he's
a real nice guy too
so it was fun yeah so you spar with a
bunch of people in there right so
you know so it's not just an actual
mushroom he can throw some hands no
oscar
he was moving around i've been trying to
get him back in there a little bit more
but yeah no he was a little brandeis
he was good you got to but i get in
there with everybody henry you know
whether or not
and the best thing is is with when you
get in there with the real pros
you know they know how to work they know
how to obviously anything to prove and
so they're real cool with you so that's
why i was like jumping in with everybody
yeah that's so sad man yeah but i fought
on a lot of freddie smokers too oh no
yeah so he has those little three-round
smokers and i miss this stuff
oh it's fun man young and the ham was
just popping yeah yeah yeah
i just wasn't durant exactly every month
right no man those are fun and then you
uh you know last thing you want to do is
lose to some hollywood kid right so
i'm always getting everybody's best but
it's fun the irony is it makes me feel
young but as i got an older kid
all my injuries have given from boxing i
tore my achilles
i told my biceps muscle i told my
rotator cuff oh boxing not wrestling or
anything which is chris
but i still get in there even though
they're advising again that's a complex
boy i don't even believe i did this
though no you never even
you never even like had have you had any
serious injuries mike did you know
damn god thank god but yeah it's uh
it's like a blur yeah right yeah a lot
of these things almost like i think of
your story martin
a lot of like from what i remember use
from the save by the bell days sure and
even before i even started wrestling i
remember
you were the first guy that we saw in a
wrestling singlet
right you know on the show and obviously
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right
you know what's funny is he wasn't even
supposed to be a wrestler like my
character i say by the bell
he was just supposed to be like some
street kid kind of like vinnie bobberino
and welcome back cotter
but they have a jock though yeah well
you know what they did is they had us
write down all the stuff that we were
into in school so i wrote down y'all you
know i wrestled
dance played the drums and then they
incorporated all that into the character
the accordion yeah did you play the
accordion
i can't it's a mexican thing
no no so i didn't know so they
incorporated that into the show and then
um
uh they just kind of made it part of the
character so people think i was copying
the character but the character was
copying me
hey you ever been ryan garcia right yeah
of course
of course i always called mcgivery
carson
yeah hey you know i try to mix it up
like the way the show has flourished
with like save other bellman how much do
you how much you owe to that show that's
giving you opera i imagine that was a
show that really gives you that
opportunity right to start now you're in
access hollywood yeah yeah i mean even
before that because
now when people always see me say i'm
you know saved by the belt he
he keeps the name living yeah well the
show hadn't been off the air since 1989
which is a trip
that old but um yeah so what is that
30-something years and so
like i said then we're doing like the
new reboot right now but even prior to
that i was on a show
when i was like 10 years old i started a
show called kids incorporated yeah i'm a
mess
you remember that come on mike we were
singing and dancing to do it all so that
was another one
it was like that was like a little like
um uh
like a mickey mouse club yeah right but
like about a band about these these kids
in this band and stuff so i did that
even before yeah
and then after that i started doing
other stuff then i got in to say about
the battle you think you could teach
hands you gotta act
henry henry henry's been acting henry's
been acting right here
this other there it is right there the
werewolf right
he's in the character right here
he's committed to it on ig and
everything i see it
had this shirt off i know ig had the
shirt off and everything
yeah like i keep it i keep up but follow
both of y'all so yeah
the thing with my character mike it's
like my character is like being cringed
it's like you can never go wrong with it
because whether you're funny you're not
like it's just cringe you know what i'm
saying yeah you know you embraced it
to do man screw it i hope i'm not boring
you mike
[Laughter]
no mike always keeps it real too so
that's why i've always been yeah
a lot of projects too you have going i
know you've been dabbling too with
tequila
yeah yeah
yes i've been doing that i partnered up
with that um it's going good you know
something kind of fun i never thought
something i'd get into it and actually
coincidentally with uh
with de la hoya with uh with oscar we're
partners in that that's pretty awesome
yeah casa mexico tequila is what it's
called it's really good tequila
and uh we actually went down to jalisco
and the plant not too long ago okay just
to kind of visit everyone
tequila tequila mexico yeah yeah mexico
tequila is the name of it you know we
got silver
reposado and nieko and it's uh and it's
good that was good
[ __ ] up it'll get you [ __ ] up
it'll do the trick but if you have
really good tequila and just the tequila
you won't have a hangover because of the
agave right there no i used to drink
everything what was your drink of choice
what'd you like
anything what um louis the 13th
cognac oh yeah it's corny anything
contact her neck is good too oh that
that yeah
that that that doesn't i mean you got to
be honest
yeah but when it hits you it's like an
uppercut that came from nowhere huh
yeah but no it's been sometimes it's
been some time though right mike since
you drank right you
you haven't got it oh good for you do
you find it hard is it hard i haven't
thought about it i did that toad [ __ ]
and wiped it i'm telling you people
think i'm lying
i did just told you take this push you
throw it in the wind um in the mirror it
dries off
yeah fine dust you smoke it
and it gives you food you go to heaven
yeah and now you're cool hey do you like
gummies
the edibles nothing edible nothing
edible
no because i don't know when it's going
to hit me he don't what i do
okay you like the edibles yeah yeah so
it just
for recreational does it help you with
the injuries um a little bit i think to
sleep
listen i think some edibles in mature
boom hit you an hour later yeah yeah and
i'm prepared for it
i can't i can't do that i just can't
wait
unless it's a going-to-bed move for me
not really mike i've seen i do
you uh it takes a lot to get them all
dude
i bet so i think i think uh no no i've
been hearing some good things
though they're beautiful yeah
i had to calm down every show i always
had to do a handful of shrooms
that's what i was hearing like what's
like tell me the difference between that
and like
when you're just gonna smoke it out
mushrooms yeah
the mushrooms can make you think that
your garden everybody's here is just for
your entertainment and stuff and
unfor real this is not really real the
world is just here
amusement damn that's deep whoa it's
crazy right
how long does it last i don't know it's
gonna last for a while
it can last a while do you do you sleep
okay
no you can't sleep oh you can't sleep
okay i don't know no but that's that's
partially what got him into the other
i mean the toad is what really did it
for for mike okay you know what i'm
saying that a lot of
330 pounds i remember and then boom
i just smoked the toes they're getting
shaped and i smoked it against it
just [ __ ] some [ __ ] out well excuse me
so when you ate because when i because i
was there when you fought jones
which you won by the way i don't know
why they did this no i know i know what
charity but um
you were smoking before huh yeah why not
yeah no i didn't know what to do i
wasn't smoking i wouldn't fight if i
didn't smoke
really
but what about your reflexes mike how
was that oh that was i think it was good
it was good
i'm trying to kill him yeah okay
okay i just didn't know if you know on
point you want to be
a bigger guy i love that scene speaking
about them and would you ever want to
get into legends league with uh with
mike
you're not with mike
uh oh one of the paul brothers right
there you know it's funny because i
hosted those fights i hope
that one hosted yours right there look
i'm not opposed to
the big events that they have i think i
do you agree with me mike i think all
attention is good for the sport if it's
going to raise the sport of boxing
i think it's all good right hell yeah
yeah see
you get it those guys those guys help
boxers
right no boxer that's why everybody
wants to fight them they got like what
everybody got 700 million views or
something
yeah he when we fought when we had 80
million views watching him
yeah i see it i think it's out of that
expression what is a high tides raise
all boats so i think i think everyone
wins of course
so you don't you don't think it's
affecting the you don't think it's it's
affecting the sport of boxing
i think it's in i think it falls under
the entertainment category and i think
like
like the movie exactly exactly and if
the spot
exactly as long as they're bored look
the fact that i i really do i feel that
the fact that the word boxing is being
um talked about so much and the
attention is there and it's raising the
awareness level it can't help but
have a benefit towards everyone are you
coming from a place of like the fighters
who have
put in all of these i'm just asking you
i
actually agree with you yeah these guys
make boxing so awesome
yeah you know boxers get angry because
the boxers like the real champions don't
even have that many views
right they haven't happy they have a
million views yeah
these guys are 80 million views i was
listening i was like god
damn man how do you do that yeah
everybody wants to kill them because
they see this little white guy blonde
hair blue eyes making all the [ __ ]
money talking all this [ __ ] yeah
everybody wants to kill him yeah hey
he's clever like a fox
yeah he's been able to get obvious when
i see these guys yeah what the [ __ ]
but i think on the flip side you want to
kick it back envy or something so it's
easy to hate those guys no
right and this is like some new era
stuff right because they became
popular on youtube and they created
their own uh following and allegiance of
fans and then they brought them over
i mean like they could have kind of
chosen any kind of he goes around
hitting people in the head with water
bottles and everything yeah he snatched
the floor half floor tried to kill him
though
yeah hey but hey try to get that hat on
right there
he shouldn't let that his dome wasn't
clean
wasn't right you know what i'm talking
about no but i mean even floyd gets it's
going in there he sees he sees the uh
uh the revenue that it can generate and
that it's obviously going to be
pretty lucrative to him but listen no
matter what all jokes aside anybody that
steps in the ring
because believe me being in there i give
props to anyone i have respect for
anyone that steps in the ring when i did
that after the fighting came back
i said i'm never gonna call a fighter
above him again cause when i had
i was oh [ __ ] my first time spawning i
got the [ __ ] kicked out
when you haven't done it in a minute
right it hits the ring but never once i
say what the [ __ ] am i doing here
i'm in the right place yeah yeah it was
ringing the hose
back
[Laughter]
right it's like dang man it's hard to
get there but i will say something about
youtube boxing i think is gonna
help the guys that the number ones like
this like the terence crawford and uh
aerospace and arrow spencer it's gonna
force these dudes to fight sooner rather
than later
those guys want to fight the youtube
guys well that's where they get there
yeah the pro here's the problem no no
that'll be a problem you know what i'm
saying because
listen floyd's been fighting with all
those guys right now
floyd right now the best fighter even
though he's 47
he's still betting all the fighters now
and he's fighting youtuber mm-hmm
yeah he's making more money than the
champion to make it gruffin and flip to
other guys yeah but that's what i'm
saying though mike this is where i would
have a problem if these
the guy floyd's retired man floyd can do
whatever he wants i would say the guys
that are active they're trying to take
fights with these dudes
they're gonna you know what i'm saying
terence crawford and earl spence when
are they gonna fight well that's the
irony
and the sort of hypocrisy with the sport
too because as opposed to
um the ufc for example where dana white
has a monopoly and all that he can
control
and kind of set the price and do you
know do what he wants right and you can
get the matchups you want to see in from
a fan's perspective it's great because
you see number one fight number two all
the time
with boxing being so fragmented and
having so many promoters as you know in
different factions
it's difficult not only to make the
match-ups but ironically you make more
money
because of that because you're able to
have the opportunities around
negotiations
the fight the only thing a fighter need
is a trainer and a lawyer
you're exactly right don't need all
these buddies don't need the bodyguard
the trainer and the lawyer
so you can the fighters can demand it
and they can make it happen if they can
make it go to but you got too many
people in your ear
saying oh you don't need that or you're
worth this and you're worth that and
then you end up i just want to clean it
out first then we're going to talk about
i know i get all the money now once i
clean everything out
yeah i demand everything yeah yeah but
i'm not worried about giving me this
give me this now you don't have to give
me nothing now
right just let me clean it out and it's
crazy because it's not so many
not even guys like jake paul like
anybody that loves a sport of boxing
that's a celebrity can make something
big out of it
you know how many people would love to
see man dude i'd pay to watch you and
not your fight
[Laughter]
that'd be a good sign that you guys
would i'm down for charity
i'm down for charity you just kind of
get up there you know
i don't know if nbc would allow me too
much but i'm sure for a charitable
component
please no usher's my homie i have no
issue with usher your start on that
but i would be happy to get in there on
a charitable
uh no but you know what i'm saying like
somebody that's somebody that would be
well recognized that sure that has a
fight background no no right
hey you know i'm down to get in there
with anybody mike i'm down to you know
what i'm saying
especially if it's going to be in the
entertainment field if not i'm down to
get in there i didn't think it would be
that hard to come back
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah
all your backstory you got to start
moving people throwing punches hard
but the conditioning is different right
mike you can think you're in shape but
then when you're in fighting shape
that's the only thing and but i could
tell you something though like
mike does change when he was in fight
camp you're a lot more serious
he'd go to the gym he trained you know
what i'm saying we're you know right now
we're shooting this [ __ ] but when he's
training dude it's like it's in the zone
of course
you know what i'm saying like those
nerves never leave i'm like
this is a different world you know you
can get humiliated
you get [ __ ] up a lot of things can
happen in that ring
that's when you're the most vulnerable
yeah and they're by yourself that's the
purest form of sport
one-on-one yeah no one to to rely on no
one to have your back it's just you in
there man
yeah well you know all about that fool
so what am i saying yeah no no i didn't
know it and that's the way it is man
this is why you know guys this is why
fighters are pretty well respected like
worldwide oh of course because they know
that it takes some grit
some balls man to go in there in front
of 25 000 people oh no it's
the biggest metaphor for life exactly as
a metaphor because we're all fighters
yep right you're exactly right we're all
fighters we all get knocked down it's a
matter if you want to get back up and
you want to keep persevering and keep
moving forward
exactly everybody has cats
mothers dogs yeah everybody's battling
something
yeah everyone's battling something
that's why it was important for me to
get my kids
into it see i got three kids and three
kids now ten
seven and one wow so you know
they're they're little guys still you
close are you closing the shop dude are
you gonna keep uh
well i should know i would keep going it
was up to me but you know i'm not the
one having them so
yeah yeah what is your what is it what
does your wife say i'm trying to i'm
trying to kind of work on it
i've been putting a lot of work in so we
may get a surprise and who knows yeah
so later so later on but that's one
thing's mexicans how many babies do you
have henry
how many kids you don't have anything
right i don't have any kids i'm gonna
announce it right now mike you're
pregnant you pregnant
goodbye you're pregnant your girl
pregnant man look not you fools you go
pregnant
yeah dude i'm actually gonna oh are you
really yeah my girl's pregnant
oh that's great breaking news
congratulations that's late for a
mexican that's good
it is it is no it really is but in
reality you know you know what i'm
saying mike being
coming from mexican descent like you
know 18 19
20. five kids this is good
we don't need to depend on people
everybody can get their own job their
own money
so people get married later yeah more
independent now i feel like i've done it
right though mike you know what i'm
saying like it's you know 34 i you know
i made some money i'm not not the money
that i necessarily want
but i have enough money to be like all
right man to start to invest in yeah as
long as you start that next chapter
nobody knows when it's right who knows
when that's right knowing them knows
when that's right you're right there is
no plan there's no
that's right yeah so i've been reading a
bunch of books on like uh on pregnancy
and things like that like what a woman
goes through man for nine months
yeah you know what i'm saying just hey
just be there and be like whatever you
need honey and just say yes
so so a synth yeah hey trust me it'll go
a long way
later on but that's good now do you know
where you're having you're going to wait
no no
i'm actually i'm going to have a little
girl baby girl oh you already know
your girl okay yeah we did it throughout
so i went to brazil brazilian
uh america america america is your
girl's name
no the the baby yeah you already got the
name for it okay oh you got the name is
there
just uh you thought about it obviously
why am i for a minute i've always wanted
a little girl men you know and i've
always thought about it and
sure enough i'm not surprised that i'm
having one so i just feel like i got to
soften up a little bit
you know yeah you'll see you'll hold
them one time that's it you're done
it's going to be easy man that's awesome
man good for you yeah good for you
brother yeah so i'm excited dude i'm
excited man first time
what did you do hungry and more
determined she's she's doing she's due
november 21st okay and yeah but
for sure mike i already feel like i'm
thinking different yeah
exactly you do you still well and then
once they're here
where i was i was going my thing it was
so see i i've always loved
obviously fighting martial arts and all
that so it was important for my
for my kids my daughter's starting to
get into it too that's why i love
getting them into like wrestling in
boxing not i mean obviously not just for
the physical aspect but it gives you so
much confidence
exactly you know what i mean just in
life it gives you confidence
you feel assured um i think just the
respect
factor in it all the disciplines you
need like in life don't you agree
yeah yeah i'm feeling it now but like
i've experienced a lot of cool things
dude
but i haven't experienced like what the
average person would probably experience
you know what i'm saying i'm 34 years
old and i'm finally first
having a kid yeah that's okay i'm still
young dude yeah no for sure but for sure
for sure but you're only nine
the first one yeah yeah no it's good
you're a little you're young but
you're a little older to appreciate a
little bit more so that's good right
and i would have waited actually what's
the crazy part about i would have waited
a couple more years
you know what i'm saying because there's
some like you're right dude
your pull-out game is weak then
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
ain't nobody trying to look at your
hooded monster henry
boxing i don't know mike's about to pull
down something that's good henry
yeah so i'm excited about because of
that you know what i'm saying because i
grew up i grew up with a single parent
home
and now that i'm going to be a a father
dude it's like dude this is this this
[ __ ] is new to me
are you getting married yeah man so i
proposed so we went down to brazil
before we had to pay the baby reveal
party but i had a
you know her whole family was there so i
had a you know traditional nathan [ __ ] i
gotta i got on one
[Laughter]
where'd you meet homegirl you've been in
the knee man i'm bad in the
yeah i met her in brazil she's very she
wrote traditional
her her she was raised by her great
grandmother
so and her great-grandmother just passed
away due to covert like about a month
ago
okay and then she found out she was
pregnant with my baby like the day that
her
great-grandmother died oh wow okay so it
was weird man she had a dream about her
great-grandma and she said
i took a test because i thought this
stuff was weird yeah next you know what
the next day yep sure enough
you know you're pregnant hey she's
pregnant i'm not pregnant if you're not
i hear you
you're pregnant you gotta you gotta
start saying that in front of her she'll
like that
it's like a community team everywhere
you're pregnant
we're pregnant see mike knows what's up
mike knows what's up
baby that's good yeah bro so i keep it
going so i did it so mike i did it in
front of like the family man which was
like you know
yeah i bent the knee but you know i had
i had i had to man because i felt like i
owed that
to be responsible yeah he's responsible
brother exactly
hey it's a game changer you'll like it
trust me you're not going to be here
long
in life you have to do something yeah at
least something behind that's right yeah
or else what's the point yeah exactly
yeah speaking about proposals mike have
you ever
ever proposed or anything like that mike
absolutely yeah
yeah so tell me how was it how was your
proposal man
let's get married just like that just
you guys are
let's get married no yeah i took a
shower
i put on my suit and i believe um
i don't know what she did she was coming
in from the store she was
dressed next to us to get married really
kids
let's get married did she say yes right
away
yeah she was asking me to get married
before get the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so it was more like ah let's get married
no i wish i was like
let's get married that's tight so what
about you marvel man
i did hey i know there's this rico suave
man no no
no i've been with my girl now like 13
years it's been a minute yes
12 years yeah okay yeah we're on the
same program right there
yeah but yeah but how did you propose
i'm about to be 48 though so is that i
propose i'll tell you how
i was in mexico too i was in zihuatanejo
remember that you heard that place yeah
yeah remember in um
shawshank redemption yeah they wanted to
go chill down there so
we were over there yeah next up very
good and it was on the beach and the
whole thing
and so you know had the ring out got on
the knee
they remember all that they remember all
that i had mariachis had mariachis
playing and stuff i hit the thing the
mariachi started
then we got hammered it was great that's
what's up dude how did you do did you
bring it on a plate like was it like yo
no no i had it with a dessert no i had
it in my pocket but you know it was a
trip i remember for some reason when i
was going through security at the
airport and
i had it in my pocket i didn't want to
lose it it buzzed and he wanted to see
it and i was like [ __ ] i didn't want to
so i told the guy hey can i talk to you
for a second so he had to take me around
and i had to say hey look here's the
ring this man i go you know
i didn't want to bring it out in front
of me so he was cool about it and stuff
most of the time they would have made
you bring it out right there and i
had to do it right there at lax i'm
gonna mean one oh [ __ ]
let's get married turn into a different
kind of show what i was thinking about
yeah you got the t-shirt she was like dr
phil right here
no but it's kubex i know mike you got
seven kids right mike
yes yeah i can't shoot blanks
you get snip mike huh do you get snip
why well i'm just saying you have it
anymore
no i'm not my kid no no okay if
my wife to the money because the movie
you're not pay
you never know i know why it's like hey
after this next one you got to get
snipped tomorrow [ __ ] i don't know
who knows that mike my wife don't wait
for him no more
okay and that's it yeah i don't want any
more kids
no no okay that's a good number you guys
you're straight good they're good kids
too oh that's good that's the best
that's important
did they ever ask you about dad show me
and
they're not their kindness yeah little
kids they're smart
kids that's cool yeah it's not like i
want my kids necessarily to fight but i
do want them to know
yeah and again i just think it's
important i like all the the disciplines
that it comes with
yeah and the respect factor right
because obviously i keep up with you man
i see
you know the way you treat your kids you
do a lot of family stuff with them
yeah a lot of dances and things like
that that's my daughter
yeah and well they they all have a
personality dude like you can tell they
ain't shy man yeah yeah no no no
no no dancing when you say the dancing
generation of lopez and show business
there you go exactly that's we're trying
trying to get the whole you know
family and gigi right i can see i can
see i can see both gigi and nicole uh
she comes out actually in the new
christmas movie with me yeah my daughter
does she's she's the name of it it's
called holiday in santa fe
yeah it takes place in santa fe new
mexico she does a really good job in it
actually she plays my niece nowhere it's
like you know a romantic
a romantic kind of uh okay so you're the
uncle and she's the niece
i'm the uncle she's the niece and we own
a family shop and it's about to get
bought out by a corporation but a woman
comes and
yeah save another day yeah i kind of say
the day we fall in love yeah
yeah okay okay a little more to it than
that but yeah it'll be good
more babies popping up after that movie
right yeah but it's gonna be fun man so
yeah so doing all that so yeah so you
know like i said
you know blessed and happy to be working
and all that but i still love to i still
love to get in there
both the boxing and the jiu jitsu and
the wrestling the whole thing right even
doing a little bit
you're getting torn apart man i know
that's the thing i feel like remember
the end
remember in the blues brothers at the
end the car that comes and just goes
apart that's how my body feels
well right now thank god i feel good i
haven't gotten injured i'm feeling
strong
i was at the gym this morning i'm
sparring wednesday almost bar wednesday
in the morning so boxing but then
tomorrow i got jiu jitsu so i try to mix
it up okay so you do it like dab or how
many rounds you typically do when you
spar
it depends like if i'm gonna go with one
guy usually he'll get a little bit tired
on me we're gonna go a couple different
guys last time i went i did like six
rounds
six rounds sparring straight you know
and they do the 30 second rest there
shit's hard yeah i know it is you got to
build up to it you can't
you got it you got it yeah and then you
learn like might you start learning how
to relax a little bit
yeah like you know don't blow your why
you don't want to blow your wad it's all
about being selected
exactly hey you sleep so good though at
night yeah yeah
i actually kind of i actually kind of
miss like just sparring but just
boxing yeah because boxing's so
it's it's only it's it's the hands dude
you got to protect this side but you got
to just find pockets and where to hit
hey when you're training on the mma you
can't obviously
go when you're sparring full force with
the boxing and the kicks or how does it
or
can how does it work because then you
have the big gloves how are you going to
grapple no
how does it work no you could i mean you
focus on one discipline no no no i don't
i don't do that no more
every time everything i do now is all
based on mma but you just find bigger
gloves
actually vtor belford created some
gloves were your were there like
normal boxing gloves but then you're
able to grab with the actual hands
with a trip yeah so you're able to kind
of come out of the glove
huh which is cool you know you can hit
them that's a trick and you can grab
them yeah yeah yeah
so can you believe they throw a four
ounce gloves
[ __ ] one ounce gloves that's like a
batting glove that's okay they're good
you ain't catching too many shelf four
ounce clothes that doesn't need too much
well i even
i even think in thailand they uh they
actually they legitimately
knocked out of the gate was muffin top
what's the thing
oh yeah oh that was a pretty left hook
boom
uzman's gotten better with the striking
man he looked good and mazda
was the one that was supposed to be
pretty sharp with his hands but he did a
nice little faint a big left hook
straight right hand down the pipe that
was pretty
yeah he's got a that was pretty it's his
leverage bro i think that's what makes
us
kamaru he's a wrestler and he's a
wrestler but it's his leverage i'm look
at his
reach bro and then look at how big he is
for that week
i think like wrestlers have heavy hands
dude it seems that way
yeah i mean besides ben ashram but yeah
the majority oh
slash that was like i don't know i
thought i was so tripping on that like
homie taking
shots by robbie lawler all these dudes
and that was gonna put you down with the
one i mean gosh dude
that was a mean one i was i was
surprised by that be honest i'm glad you
didn't let him hit him again
no i know that was cool that he didn't
let him him again homie was all smiling
afterwards oh
yeah but were you a little surprised by
that no no i knew i knew he was gonna
get knocked actually call it i was gonna
give him like round two
with one shot but ben has ben has no
hands bro like
no i know but he has a good chin he
showed that's why i was surprised
because you've seen him take some hard
shots before
yeah that's why i was surprised yeah but
having a good chin is not like a good uh
no but he's taking great shots before us
because i figured with
what were they fighting with 10 ounce
right so that was i was surprised
yeah but then he came out he came out of
hip surgery and and all that like yeah
yeah
he had no business and they made good
money too yeah
i think he probably i think he probably
made a million dollars i think
yeah it wasn't good for him you know
price fighting
that's what it's all about right it just
kind of hurts them and make him uh you
know
it's just now clarissa shields did you
hear about that mike
thought going into ufc yeah you know
she's going to be fighting the pfl
sometime next i think june 7th or june
8th oh is it pfl she's fighting good
carla i think okay but as good as she is
of a boxer
mike i'm not sure she can i'm not sure
she might she's going to be in trouble
bro to say the least
because i ain't trying to see it yeah
but it's going to show us that but henry
and correct me if i'm wrong
it's not like it's very different if you
haven't
grown up wrestling or grappling because
you can't just your instincts just to
learn how to sprawl and just
that takes a lot of mat time just like
boxing learning how to roll
am i right you can't just learn how to
sprawl and grapple overnight ken you
can't hear that you're the greatest
athlete of all time
right exactly i can't prepare for the
pressure of that you know when a guy
greg what the [ __ ] do i do
right exactly exactly they grab yourself
you're gonna hook them and they have
both your hands oh that's it
once you get on the ground that's it all
the boxing's gone that's what i'm saying
so what i'm saying my prediction is
and i'm not hating on clarissa shield
but she's in trouble with the average
girl in mixed martial arts because
of the take down
you know if she does man i'd be like
dude i will bend the knee to her too
marry her he's gonna marry her too he's
gonna have a harem over here can you
marry two times
yeah yeah you can you can
henry let me ask you would you say how
far did you get in jiu jitsu
with your jiu jitsu uh i'll be honest
with you i i didn't i'd use more
i want to hurt people more than actually
submit people no i know but i'm saying
like in the training how far would you
say
i don't even go past so i even go past a
white belt is that right yeah so
so that wasn't it so it was more about
just the grappling it was more of yeah
but i could submit people
yeah like black belts and i've actually
submitted world champions before with
just some of my wrestling skills
from just the wrestlers like yeah they
don't know
in the pressure right and then you wear
them out and you wear them out you wear
them actually you know things just fall
into your hands yeah
that's a trip yeah yeah but you're right
that's that's maybe that's one art that
i probably
should have but man i want to hurt
people you know
yeah yeah yeah elbow
you hear this man yeah violin huh
he's all violent over here i like hey
you know what i've been in the last i
was at the teleshow one i was at the
mighty last one
oh yeah yeah i was at the one you see
the mariah's did you see when i thought
marlon mariah yeah i wasn't at that one
but i saw that one that was great that
was probably one of the best comebacks
i've ever seen yeah
yeah mma i'm gonna give them props on
that one i thought i ain't gonna lie
after that first round i go oh [ __ ]
he kicks you one more time i said my
guy's gone that was one of the best came
back
baby ain't nobody got that mexican
warrior
build that spirit in the uh where would
that knowledge to adjust
man yeah well i had to because you know
what i'm saying you've been there before
right michael you had to adjust now you
didn't get [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
mike a lot of guys don't know how to
make the adjustment they make they know
how to fight one way and then they don't
know how to make it that
just like life if you don't right you
die yep
that's exactly like you said fighting's
like life you're exactly right if you
don't adapt you die damn
mike's coming with some knowledge oh
yeah don't get them started bro
they have some some mushrooms
[Music]
[Laughter]
man that's what's up mario man well any
new pro i mean other than uh any new
projects in the future that you're
planning on baby playing next year got
anything to do with you
with what i'm sorry are you working with
netflix i i just did a show with them we
ended i was producing a show over there
called the expanding universe of ashley
garcia
we finished that one but um at the
moment
no at the moment no but uh you know we
got the new
like i said say for the bell season
coming out on peacock that's one of
those new streaming services too
for nbc and then we got some other stuff
so some other fun exciting stuff
yeah that's cool man speaking about the
like i think uh was it uh
dustin diamond passed away screech yeah
he just passed away not too long ago
right he did man he was young poor guy
he's two months ago right
yes he did as a matter of fact he had
cancer and when he went to go get a
checkup it was already like stage four
and literally two weeks later two weeks
boom that was it poor guy happened to
anybody not too late for that
anybody yeah it was like a i believe
like a throat
type of cancer something around this
like lymph node throat something like
that
you know poor guy you never know man you
know one of those things yeah
why you laughing fool that ain't funny
no no i'm saying this screech
i remember
no because i remember screech how you
fought china so that's what came to mind
remember you fought china the celebrity
match
he did
[ __ ] him up but no he didn't fight
china fool he didn't fight a woman
i swear to you he did dude i swear to
you
look it up dude look at him i promise
you i promise he did not fight him
he [ __ ] up man yeah he [ __ ] horse
shack up he did he put horse jack up
more screeching either that whatever i
just smoked right now it's freaking it's
hard man
henry's going to be a dad dude yeah you
don't have to change
that brother yes or no oh he didn't
fight china huh he never fought china
that's awful
he might have been to china he didn't
fight china yeah
oh that little dude with the bagel
[ __ ] dude dustin diamond versus china
did you look that up yeah
you didn't like him hey for a charity
thing who do you think i should step in
with
who'd be cool man i would love one of
those dj's or rappers i would love to
see you against uh one of the jonas
brothers i think they i think they uh
why
[Laughter]
you can't just walk over those guys well
what do you mean mike punks and stuff no
no
you see what i'm saying i i don't i hey
anybody
like i said do they train okay i'm just
thinking of guys the other guy that i
can think of maybe uh
wes khalifa dude
nick jonas where's khalifa that's tight
you got a lot of faith in me henry
gosh damn henry [ __ ] i'm trying to build
your
hey brother know both those dudes
they're both cool dudes
so that's cool man yeah there's there's
a lot of celebrities now like i see even
justin bieber's around the game a lot
too
yeah he likes it he likes it a lot he
was at the the last event right there
trailer likes to i mean pardon me um
uh bieber likes to train who else have i
seen that matthew mcconaughey i've seen
in the gyms
my boy mark wahlberg likes to train not
so much anymore you know who i would
like to fight with
i would love to fight with holly berry
hollywood
why not dude
[Laughter]
halle berry i'm calling you out
i'm calling you out jennifer lopez
because they
they look incredible they look
incredible they look incredible they
were 30.
yeah yeah just crazy and you you've
actually aged very very well too
homie's clearly been taking shrooms he's
right here no i appreciate it no every
everybody everybody dude look he still
looks like he's like he was
that kid and said by the boat in the gym
with the gym rack
that's right did you stay in there mike
that's what's up staying there
friends are cool tell
your diet ben obviously you gotta are
you pretty you know what i really don't
i really don't
like diet per se i try to like no i try
not to eat like an [ __ ] during the
week and
to kind of try to watch what i eat on
the weekends i get down i love to eat
controlled during the week
you know i try to control and i kind of
do a little bit like mike like if i
didn't get a chance to train that i
won't eat too crazy you know
it's more about i don't feel like you
should ever eliminate any kind of food
especially if you like it i like to
kind of pace myself but on the weekends
i like to get a little crazy yeah yeah
you know i'll i'll throw it down yeah
what's your cheat meal man what do you
what is it i'll crush it what is it on
weekends that you'd be like man this is
i'm gonna
oh dude i'm about to eat this thing
kylie well
lemon lemon what's that lemon pie key
lime pie
i love it i love it i mean i crushed me
easy a good 12 to
13 taco is easy wow man i'm gonna get
somebody's goals right there
mean pizza all that stuff i leave all
this [ __ ] i like sweets too i ain't
gonna lie
like yeah i like chocolates and stuff
i'm like a little fat kid
i love sweet great hot cookies and hot
chocolate
yeah yeah i love all that [ __ ] yeah but
that's on the weekends because then if
not i'll be off
damn well that's what's up man
you guys are making me hungry out here i
know and are you going to come back and
fight man or what you keep teasing yeah
i'm going to
say that man get in shape and come back
you know i am no i i haven't no i'm not
out of shape i'm actually i'm actually
you know i
i work out i don't i don't fight as as
much as i used to it's actually been one
year since my last
competition you need to get back in the
gym and stuff getting back to shop again
yeah are you thinking about seriously
making a comeback or are you thinking
about maybe training or getting involved
in some capacity because i know you
officially
retired yeah yeah right now i'm in
business man i'm in real estate
did i i've been wrestling since i was 11
and then i've been
pretty much since age 11 to age 33 i
thought i'd be doing this competing
yeah mma wrestling and mma and man i've
been enjoying business i've been joining
i've been enjoying coming out here with
mike you know hot boxing with him but do
you want to be involved in the game
still in some capacity whether it's
training managing not really dude i'm
saying yeah
it's like i just want to exit out
completely you know not completely but
always a fan
yeah but i don't know if i want to be
you know what i'm saying in there
because
yeah because i know mike one of one
things i always loved about mike too
he's a historian
so he knows all this stuff all the time
love watching the old fights and you
still love watching fights even now
which i love
too yeah you know so that's what i love
it's like when you're also a fan because
there's a lot of guys that fight that
hate it they hate to watch it
they do watch their opponent train yeah
they don't even like to watch the stuff
no he loves it so that's what's cool
i think i think but the biggest thing
with me is just it's not like boxing man
like
you know the ufc is like it has to be
worth the legacy man you know what i'm
saying that yeah i've done everything
there is to do bro
no you have nothing else to call i was
just curious if you were going to be um
involved
but that's what i'm support to some
capacity that's awesome um yeah i mean i
love to analyze like
uh actually espn uh sports nations are
giving me like a five minute segment
on just kind of like being cringed like
giving fight analysis but being the
character that i am
so okay and also it's a cartoon about
you man let me cartoon about you yeah
see but mike's had a video let's see
that's right and you see the place to be
that's the best he had a cartoon in the
best video game ever yeah hey i remember
i don't think i ever told you mike when
i finally got to you
and i had a beat [ __ ] took me like
months to finally get to and finally
i was like i was like and then you
knocked my ass out like it just sucks
and then there was a code i remember
there was a code the way i
remember to get the right to the thing
that was the best like up down up down
left right let's get to the post
hit the bike oh to get to him just to
fight him yeah i'm older than you so you
went around
no i remember my touching pushup but i
never got to mike oh no i got to him but
i was like
real quick
all right fool you done with me or
what's up mario lopez man it is uh
it is a pleasure it is an honor man
over time man we love you man hey man
you know i got that
love and respect for you and you too
henry seriously sitting with real
champions not just in the ring in the
octagon but in life and real cool dudes
so uh mad respect for both of you i
appreciate you uh having me now i'm
gonna go try some extracurricular
activities like
absolutely man don't forget june 5th man
come to the
opening of tyson lounge i love it
tyson's lounge this is the
i'm gonna come to the lounge in the
ranch yeah the ranch is good
with mike tyson yes yes
and i'm here here we go mario lopez
thanks again for coming dude this is a
blast and he lost
let's you want to close it out for us
yeah tell us about you man
look the whole world is looking at you
2.5 billion people
say something thank you for having me on
the show mad respect to both of you
uh gentlemen appreciate the time if you
find yourself in front of the tv around
seven o'clock tune in nbc
access hollywood or the radio tune in to
on with mario or check out the news
saved by the bell or the christmas movie
coming out i got to plug all this [ __ ]
later on i gotta put it and hopefully
you'll find me somebody to fight henry
since you're putting in there for the
charitable aspect what the hell am i
putting all this damn
time in the i should just go usher man
poor usher man why you all want to get
us you're lumped up
yeah that's caught his eyes
[Music]
meow
you